«Es war besonders wild, ...
... weil es 2006 war und der
Libanonkrieg losging.
Sie war bereits dort und
organisierte uns eine Wohnung.»
«Und ich war schwanger.»
«Ja, sie war schwanger.
Und plötzlich fielen Bomben in Haifa.
Ich reiste eigentlich mitten im Krieg an.
In diesem Sinn machte ich meine
extremste Erfahrung bereits am Anfang.»
«Wir haben uns im Cern getroffen.
Das ist ein Teilchenbeschleuniger in Genf.
Ich war im Sommer als Studentin dort, ...
... und Michi war auch dort.»
«Ich war mit einer kleinen Gruppe von
Computerspezialisten dort, ...
... und sie war mit einer Riesengruppe
von Physikern dort.»
«Wir haben uns in den ersten Tagen getroffen ...
... in einer Kochgruppe.»
«Es war ein Problem für meine Eltern.
Sie sind zwar nicht wirklich religiös,
aber trotzdem ein bisschen.
Mein Vater stammt aus
einer sehr religiösen Familie.
Deshalb war es am
Anfang schwierig für sie.
Aber dann haben sie Michi
besser kennen gelernt ...
... und jetzt mögen sie ihn.»
«Ich glaube die Idee dahinter war:
Gegenseitig die Kulturen kennen zu lernen.
Avigail wünschte sich, dass wir mindestens für
zwei Jahre in Israel leben.
Ich musste mir das also
schon etwas überlegen.
Wie man hier durch die News erfährt, ...
... hat man das Gefühl,
es sei fürchterlich gefährlich dort.
Doch dann dachte ich:
Ich will keinen
Defensiventscheid fällen.
Das ist eine Chance. Ich gehe jetzt
mal dorthin und schaue, wie es ist.
Zuerst sagten wir: Zwei Jahre.
Und es wurden dann zehn.»
«Es hat einen viel grösseren Effekt
aufs Leben, als man denkt.
Wenn man sich verliebt,
spielt der Hintergrund keine Rolle.
Man verliebt sich einfach.
Ich hatte mir das nie überlegt, ...
... welche Konsequenzen das ...
... auf mein Leben haben könnte.
Was am Schluss herauskommt ist:
Dass man die andere Kultur mitheiratet ...
... und dies führt letztendlich auch zu
einem total anderen Leben.
Für mich bedeutete es, dass ich
zehn Jahre in Israel lebte, ...
... was überhaupt nicht mein Plan war.
Ich hatte vorher keinen Bezug zu Israel.